[Music]
in just-in-time news watch it submitted
by Toronto loves JK we love you too
total two men who were rescued from a
flooded elevator describe the terrifying
ordeal a flood I did
what does that mean that's [ __ ] scary
like you filled up with liquid I kind of
wanted to change that but like in an
untruthful too controlled setting yeah
where I'm like the water for the water
rising like when you're in a car you
have to escape the car because it's the
crime no no no there you turn in a
controlled environment Jeff loves this
[ __ ] no I would love to experience that
if there's like a tap out button and it
can yeah cuz I want to see how far I
could push myself and but I want I need
a Tapout but Josh's dad has to do that
cuz all the people that work offshore
they have to be certified with the
[ __ ] like helicopter escape plans and
shield down there in a simulation where
they're strapped into a helicopter yeah
and then you get dumped like your
machine like whatever helicopter you're
in gets dunked in this machine that's
full of water and it simulates like a
crash and involved like all this [ __ ]
water it's now submerged and then they
tell you release so while you're in
there just holding your breath and then
you have to [ __ ] release your [ __ ]
and then try to swim and get out and
then there's like scuba divers there
with like [ __ ] just in case you need
oxygen is [ __ ] but if you have to do
that then you fail and you don't get
certified Thomas I'm a certified scuba
diver no joke and it sounds like nothing
but a joke no I am but I am a what's the
name of this search of the one you said
certification I'm [ __ ] we were
certified you would know what cert means
we talk I know I know I don't know what
the company was I remember those you
know the name of the certification you
know is it a like skydiving where you do
it a couple times with other people and
then like you get your certificate I did
not all at the same place like over and
over the same place how old are you guys
this time I was like five years ago well
let's just or are we gonna tell us no I
just wanted to say that that's it
I am a certified scuba dive see you swim
listen I'm a certified [ __ ]
scuba diver mafia it take a lot to be
certified thanks Jesus really why do you
always back sir
he always has her back he always a time
usually I bring up the sponsorship
okay don't go to brain deals you're
right but I'll make fun of anybody for
brand about the story so recently
Toronto has been flooded like it was
flooded pretty crazy and so these guys
they heard about the flooding
they went down well one of them went
down to check on his on his car cuz it
was parked in like an underground garage
underground garage in hell in Toronto oh
and and then so he took the elevator
down there was this other man that was
there or like he accompanied him and
luckily that guy was went with him by
accident cuz he was the only one that
had a cell phone they were trapped in
the elevator because the flooding
started rising and now I'm gonna play
you guys a video behind the screen door
in the basement of a downtown building
two men were trapped by the fast rising
waters I started using the elevator
buttons as a reference for how quickly
the water was rising cleaver fryer and
Gabriel autre had taken the elevator to
the basement to check on their cars when
it descended into a pool of water climb
up on the railing and tried to push the
top panel out because you know that's
what you seen in movies outside the
deluge was unrelenting but the sewers
overrun all of that water forced its way
into other low-lying places in that
elevator the threat was growing by inch
every minute there is panic there is
praying there was sighting that we're
gonna get out of there no matter what so
the only way we got it was actually
punching through the the ceiling panel
and we busted one of the panels so that
we could get the phone to get reception
eventually using their heads and hands
they got through
and within minutes two officers arrived
after two tries using crowbars they got
the doors open
we knew the situation was going on but
there's no panic we're both pretty calm
and all four men swam to safety
Canadians are so calm like the police
the citizens everyone's so sensible and
calm they're very I would have been like
his step in like [ __ ] almost died in
that [ __ ] man I'm suing this
[ __ ] elevator ass company what the
[ __ ] is going on theater ass whatever
that's [ __ ] whoever built this [ __ ]
piece of [ __ ] why is it their fault we
took its fault American white multi cuz
it went into the water American Way yeah
you gotta try to make your lawsuit work
right and I had to be like us mega hero
like I didn't know what we were gonna do
so I bust through there with my Megaman
[ __ ] arm I [ __ ] broke
through because nobody else can do it
but me hey my friend
I like that those two guys the one that
said he were punching stuff I'm like
dude you don't look like you punched
anything I bet you the other dude yes
what if I do whatever I can say that I
think it was the handsome a guy who was
punching I would agree not have no suits
well that's a different it's like a
lower opinion actually were certified I
am I remember now is patty patty what
patty the scuba diver no but really I
did get certified more you talk about it
the less I believed you I was right
there with you but now just like you
asked me a question through one agency
or whatever I said patty next question
okay what's the last day of press
conference labelled give me some gear
well what's the gear that you have to
wear Oh scuba gear okay
she's so [ __ ] stupid isn't that crazy
Jesus you know what'd be cool is like
you know how people in their offices
have a lot of [ __ ] degrees and
certifications behind them yeah I want a
bunch of jack [ __ ] certification give me
your three give me some three I'll be a
[ __ ] home appraiser certification
that one's pretty good
okay [ __ ] no
are notaries ago no no no a notary ice
cream taster that's dope legit that
makes a lot you know that's like a
[ __ ] six-figure income job yeah I
[ __ ] up Shay I walk out yeah they get
they get a lot of money are you gonna no
look up it's like sommelier man they
make it [ __ ] crush it there's only a
few someone yeah yeah [ __ ] that
walk up to you and they're like hello
sir this is a with a little hint of her
yeah okay it's so funny too cause like
you know when you go to a nice
restaurant and they have the song that
comes up the icer so what we have I'm
like listen to whatever you think is
good just pour it right in as long as
it's not too expensive yeah same
I might how much is it first of all per
glass ass okay no need to be hostile
service yeah cuz they always say stuff
that I don't I can't relate you know I
mean you have to talk to me I'm a layman
to me I'm like your job is to take as
much money as you can from me and my job
is to give you as little money as
possible while getting behind in period
fresh-cut roses on a bed of garden hose
with a little bit of chicory that's why
I don't look at waiters or Psalms as
friends I look at them as enemies always
and I and they're always trying to
hustle some new [ __ ] on you always
they'd you like a special serve do you
always recommend the most expensive
thing on the menu
guaranteed yeah what's really good here
the most expensive thing I always do
that and I always see if they're gonna
give me the most expensive thing on the
menu and then I'm like [ __ ] you dude
don't when they don't sound like oh
that's another sales tactic the second
most expensive things yeah I wouldn't
get that I'll get this
I always want to win the transaction and
so I always try to slick so if it's like
I'm from a steakhouse and they recommend
the $45 steak oh my I'll get the chicken
sometimes I feel like they choose the
cheaper one cuz they don't think I can
afford it so I go [ __ ] you and I get the
most expensive one oh that's good I
would barrel barrel and I went to a
brunch spot in your Smorgasburg right
yeah it's actually really good
what's it called poppy and Rose no it's
it they just opened up maybe a couple
months ago what's it called if you can't
name it that apparently
really well we just we just walked in
there because it was it was open next to
it and we just saw a lot of people leave
David so much right now because I had I
know that area there are new a bunch of
new businesses that no one knows what
they are you know what gives you away no
one that gets certified that there's no
the agents I don't believe you because
you're so [ __ ] pale bro like you're
scuba divers recovered about you gear
what about here why is this even wider
than oh wait you you think that I go no
I don't go scuba diving though I am a
certified scuba diver so that I can say
that I'm certified understand you got to
put hours and they get certified what
are you talking about you put like 50
hours in our central hunt I put in a
bunch hours but it's not that money
you're [ __ ] crazy I got certified in
Maui dude where they were they probably
loosen the laws for what certification
is so that people can get certified well
than their do they give you a
certificate I'm right [ __ ] you
professional association of diving
instructors Patti [ __ ] how can I
make that [ __ ] up that's pretty good
that's pretty good it's not that much
cuz you already burned my ass without
like one high eases what's the process
you have to do so you don't get oxygen
poisoning or whatever I'm [ __ ]
remembers five years ago okay now I'm a
certified scuba diver so I can say I am
I believe to go I believe in now all
right fine scuba dive you have to pull
your certification like the [ __ ]
Coast car pulls up you're like are you
scuba diving without certification like
no no yeah the coolest part about it is
there's one part where you're like 25
feet down or whatever and you have to
take off all your gear and put it pull
it in front of you and then you have to
put it back not positive so it's like
what if it drops off of your back and
then you have to good to be ready do you
know how to dive without it hurting your
ears yeah I don't use the pop-up I'm
gonna you're really all the way down
[ __ ] down I want a helmet that just
[ __ ] doesn't make my ear
never seen it before yeah yeah but
there's mics that go to the side thought
that was so if he use now does that
still looks so much fun
[Applause]
[Music]